you know what the top 10 lists for
hand-to-hand fights have been hit
so why not have one for gunfights i mean
guns are as cool as martial arts and
hand-to-hand combat don't you agree they
make for a lot of intense and exciting
sequences but instead of fists flying
you see bullets getting fired with this
video i hope you'll appreciate gunfights
just as much
i want to show you that shootouts are
every bit just as exciting as the more
physically oriented fights you've been
treated to with anime's cream of the
crop now without further ado
let's get the show rolling
starting off the list we have a mirror
match
yes it's toru vs toru in the finale of
gunslinger stratos
gunslinger stratos the animations pretty
much the textbook definition of a game
commercial
overall the plot and the animation
wouldn't be winning any awards anytime
soon but at least it did give us a
banger of a final battle where two
versions of the same character face off
with that being said though
i think that some gunfights end up being
nice spectacles
and this is one of them coming off the
big twist this gun fight does deserve
its purpose as well as the climax of the
series
oh and they made two endings to this as
well there's a good ending
and a bad ending and i remember a time
when the few who watched the show
debated on which one the anime wanted to
keep as canon now that's something you
don't see in anime too often now do you
[Music]
now with a title like gun grave you'd
probably expect a lot of cool shootouts
well this title doesn't disappoint and
it brings us to our next entry on the
list
gray versus boon g starts off just like
a lot of the shooters that you played in
the 2000s
meeting in an empty lobby the two begin
letting the bullets fly while chasing
each other to the beat of kick-ass music
in a way it kind of reminds me of those
western films with a lot of bullet time
and flying around by both combatants
flashbacks of stuff like max payne
anyone some people may find the art
style kind of dated but if you can look
past that
this encounter is a gunfight to remember
a kanan fight makes it to number eight
and it's the showdown between kanan and
alfard encountering each other inside a
train the bullets were quick to fly
in this high octane duel between the two
characters the hype was there
the tension was there so it's time for
the battle to begin
it's a long drawn-out affair that sees
the fight spilling out of the confines
of the trade and
into everywhere the two just won't stop
even as they resume fighting outside the
cabin and despite how far the trains
traveled i like this battle because of
the fact that while it's primarily a
gunfight and marketed as such the two
fighters don't limit their arsenals to
their guns
knives get thrown hair gets pulled the
hand-to-hand combat is there as well
i'm not even sure if i cheated by
putting this fight on the list actually
given how varied the direction of the
fight went but it's just such a good
fight that i wouldn't want you to miss
[Music]
it
speaking of gunfights that aren't really
direct shootouts one of the most hyped
up fights in majorca makes its entry on
this list
the opening video itself makes this out
to be the fight of destiny in the series
first half and for me it didn't
disappoint before this episode we saw a
lot of build up for masaki's dangerous
blood magic but since lethal magic's
prohibited in the tournament a lot of
viewers were instead left to wonder what
tricks masaki has in his sleeves a lot
of acrobatics in display from tatsuya as
the two leaders of their respective team
square off
you can't help but feel amazed at the
camera angles and how they show the
speed at which everything happens
just as quick as masaki makes those
magic circles tatsuya shoots them down
while rolling and flipping in the air
it's not a direct gunfight
but it's every bit as satisfying i also
find it neat that this fight ends not
with a gunshot but with the finger snap
of doom
sasuga onisama indeed
[Music]
[Music]
reappearing on another list is something
that we've covered recently
yep it's the sibling fight of the ages
featuring vash the stampede and his
brother
the two have a relatively simple fight
by modern anime standards but i can't
stress the impact and the importance of
this fight in terms of the anime
storyline the fight's filled with
tension
and shows us how knives gets the
advantage due to knowing more about
vash's trump card
their shots colliding it's a sight to
see we've been spoiled by technology and
modern animation now but this
is one of the most epic scenes that fans
two decades ago can lay witness to
not a lot of shots get fired but those
few ones that do get fired have all the
weight and power behind
them
at a halfway mark is fabiola versus the
colombian cartel there are great gun
fights that are epic clashes and back
and forth affairs and we remember them
mostly for their on-point sequences and
flashy animation
then there are one-man army moments that
while are also memorable in terms of
animation
we mostly remember them for showcasing
how strong a particular character
is this scene from black lagoon falls
into the latter category we've known the
reputation of the columbia cartel for so
long
but in this particular instance in black
lagoon they just picked the wrong hood
to mess with enter ninja maid fabiola
who runs wild on them thanks to all her
weapons and her clever utilization of
the environment to her advantage
she leaves with a beautiful massacre in
her wake showing everyone that maids are
never to be underestimated
especially in anime
taking on dimsdale boiled in mardox
scramble the third exhaust is a joy to
watch
nothing really pleases action
enthusiasts more than a nice shootout
with all the build up and tension before
the blow-off
the fight's drawn out and features a lot
of great cuts and details that will
leave you amazed and at the edge of your
seats
the sci-fi setting just adds to the
sequence and i really like just how
smooth and sleek
everything looks i think that some
people might find the color overlay a
bit distracting for this sequence but
i think that it's not that much of a big
deal i'm more concerned with how not a
lot of people know this series of movies
i mean it's a shame really you should
definitely give it a try the second good
news is that this is not the last
cinematic entry that we'll be seeing on
this list
stay tuned for more
[Music]
what a magnificent sequence of events
the final showdown between spike and
vicious is at hand but before that
spike has to go through red dragon's
headquarters what follows is an amazing
sequence of bullet hell reminiscent of
something
like max payne spike charges the
building and engages the members of the
syndicate in what seems like
reckless abandon there's no shortage of
action as he encounters enemies at every
turn
forcing him to use every weapon at his
disposal to its full potential
this includes setting bombs and making
full use of what armament he has
all to lead to a much-awaited showdown
against vicious the preceding fight
against vicious is just as amazing with
the two settling things in a more
traditional jewel complete with john woo
references
it's not a shootout but the one-on-one
final battle deserves every bit of
credit for being an epic climax to this
classic
ah the magnum opus of shaft cinematic
fights
i think that it's safe to say that this
fight is the fight that represents the
peak of madoka magicka in terms of
animation
taking place in the third movie fans
finally got the battle they never got in
the series proper pitting homura's
entire arsenal of weapons against mami's
magical muskets the two go at each other
with blitzing speed as they fly from
building to building in their fight
sparks fly and bullets spray in the
two's bid to shoot each other down with
one rare
pause in the battle giving us one of the
most iconic shots in the series where
the two point to each other with all of
those bullet lines in the foreground
madoka magicka might not be a series
known for its fight more than its themes
and symbolism
but anyone just watching this fight
won't be able to figure that out
short but sweet while mommy vs homura
was a long drawn out dance
odasaku vs gide is just about a minute
long however the two still had one
amazing and spectacular gunfight with
each fighter predicting
each other's moves and doing microsecond
dodges before firing back with a shot of
their own the sheer speed of how things
happen
is just bonkers in this i mean the only
gunfight that can beat a gunfight
between two magical girls at their peak
has to be won
involving even more broken powers am i
right yes precognition in anime can be a
tricky ability to write but when you put
two characters with similar powers and
have them go at it the result
is simply beautiful i can't stress how
context matters though to a regular
watcher the guys might seem like people
who can't shoot for [ __ ] or have epic
dodge timing
but it all makes sense once you figure
out it's basically two sharingan users
taking each other on
ten gunfights later i wonder what you
think about them do you still prefer
hand to hand fights over gun fights do
you prefer to see bullets flying or
fists flying
i'd like you to tell me your choice in
the comment section below and why
leave a like if you enjoyed the video
and don't forget to subscribe if you
haven't already for now
that's got to do it stay tuned for more
content on the next top 10 list only
here on
vinnie tube
[Music]
you